okay number 410 time so same thing
young turn BOTS don't have your line of
gravity between your two feet and it
swings out like this this is not
Marshall without the weapon shift turn
then shift turn let's try
with your head whoa then don't bring
your money poverty but with you keep a
forward orientation that's a line of
attack whoa then you have to in down ok
let's try
shift ten cards
single pivot and that's all all I'm
working on is a single pivot point
single pivot point single pivot point
to the same place as opposed to sending
our property full double to the point
underneath ok for this a nation or a
byline of gravity's between my two feet
and now I'm going to start to 10.com
leaving it there you see a double pivot
and I won't translate into the internal
aspects and it is not marginal shift
then again and with that the sword is
going to keep moving the sword keeps
moving not to move so I'm going to do
the foot maneuver constant and the sword
keep smooth don't have to go fast just
work
don't come back bring the foot back in
there's no weight on the foot if it's
out of here you know you have a big
stance line driving shift your weight
shift turning turning drive the top
shift again boom okay
don't make it so simple where you're all
in here hey try to get the authority i
turn my line and brought these over this
mid-foot then what you do is you shift
it back and this is why your mind Robin
is here and you want to push it off of
this box whoa that's a double pivot hey
again when you mess with the line of
gravity the weight distribution not only
do your internal aspects stop
functioning but your range is off so
I'll show you will do that if you go to
exercise so this measure here he's
reaching out okay so here I am
while I'm gravity is
go onto the back foot without travelling
back over here boom
if I once I put it here on the back foot
when I cut it has to go forward and I'll
be in range but find a grab this year if
I move it back with me to here I will be
out of range they're here now it's gonna
move back with me
you see I get out of range every time
okay so even if you couldn't double
pivot your my is gonna be off all right
so I go one and when I go into the turn
don't let your weight shift with
you with your inertia
hold the single pivot boom so my way to
share don't bring weight on to it then
you can have a hard time doing it again
okay try to fix now hydro energy I am
going to shift and with that young I'm
on the other side
then I tend calm into that spot okay now
if I can go behind it
whoa if I double pivot you're gonna pull
him you want to shift your weight again
exercise this that's a clash okay
what I'm doing is he's going that way I
move myself to the other side and I'm
going the same way he's going okay I get
into position
oh and now I have to do it again oh you
will get right into that same mistake if
you double pivot you can't get on the
other side okay you're gonna do these
little tricks but you're still classy
and you're moving them this way
horniness stop it's still a class i you
want to say problem if when you take on
you let your center of gravity your
any trouble block with you you can't get
there and you're going to pull now to
try and turn your your job is to
constantly be gone in his direction okay
so I move into the empty space and then
I repeat it again so I can go pretty
quick at no time am i pulling hit okay
that is incorrect
alright again okay usually we work with
a social violence so you get a spinal
displacement I want to show you that
it's not not him pushing and then that's
how this happened
okay so you could kind of even pull okay
so he's gonna pull and I'm just gonna
bring his balance this way okay so as I
come in like this it's already making
him have to readjust you see and I am
basically just doing these tiny little
readjustments to his face okay so if I
let go of the ground pop you're gonna
see that he's he's pulling okay you go
out like this
he's based now but I am pushing this
Center like that okay keep moving and I
can keep doing that there in our time
and I have a drill
and now I gotta do that tank over here
are you gonna have to do the same thing
I'm gonna push his Center they're
pushing the center where she descent
that's what I'm doing
can you understand this is just not
possible
thanks all right okay I'm basically
taking his elbow and pushing his Center
in the ditch here whoa same day I'll do
it again
okay try it
weapons and empty hand they're
concentric it's not move your hand like
you move the sword that's not it
that's a modern epistemology okay so the
the geometries that allow me to not
clash is the same geometry that allows
the sword to find the hid space as I'm
hooping around okay that's the better
way of thinking about all right so when
I come around
see enemy in chitin so ship
boom-boom young ski boom and then repeat
on the other side shifts or boots
bow-wow
make sure as you guys are doing this if
you come over here Shawn that when you
do the ski that you're not already tardy
okay so one boom under you guys do the
ski this foot is turning on you now
you're not doing the drill the ski goes
over and then the pool turns forward not
here not here forward to this point
moves all right let's go both sides